[Música]
vamos ahora a repasar las noticias más
destacadas del ámbito de la salud y ya
nos acompañan el estudio más Romero sala
bienvenida Gracias Rosa mar empezamos
atentos a una decisión que se tomará hoy
respecto al monkey pox no a la viruela
del mono sobre si continúa siendo una
emergencia de salud pública precisamente
un tema al que pues que alarmó un poco
no al mundo Aunque usted siempre trata
de rebajar un poco la alarma si yo soy
de las del equipo que quizás piensa que
con menos urgencia y menos alarma
podríamos trabajar más y conseguir más
cosas Pero bueno si hoy está reunido
este comité para evaluar si mantienen el
estatus de emergencia internacional que
se mantiene desde julio de 2022 sobre la
viruela del mono monkey poxo empox como
recomienda ahora la OMS que se llame a
esta enfermedad es la quinta reunión
desde que empezaron las preocupaciones a
raíz de este brote descontrolado en
países donde esta enfermedad no solía
ser endémica a día de hoy ha generado
más de 87.000 casos en todo el mundo y
140 muertes alrededor del globo y por
supuesto hay una noticia celebrar Y es
que desde los picos de contagio que
había por ejemplo en agosto del año
pasado cuando se reportaban más de 7.000
casos semanales estamos muy lejos de esa
situación estamos en una situación muy
distinta y ahora más o menos se reportan
algo más de un centenar de casos
semanales entonces bueno claramente Es
cierto que no estamos en el mismo
momento en el que estábamos hace un año
y eso pues nunca está de más recordar
que se ha debido en gran parte a una
implicación de la comunidad que ha
estado más afectada fuera de los países
endémicos que han sido los hombres gays
bisexuales que tenían relaciones con
otros hombres que lastimosamente tienen
una amplia pues capacidad de saber cómo
combatir enfermedades de transmisión
sexual que les afectan particularmente
también tienen mucha experiencia en
organización y autoorganización para
pedir las medidas de salud pública que
al final lograron también contener este
brote y todo esto también a pesar del
estigma cada vez más volvió a caer sobre
esta comunidad pero vamos a las cifras a
pesar de que la alarma no sea ni
remotamente parecida a la que había hace
un año Eso no significa que haya
desaparecido porque la región de las
Américas sigue siendo la región donde se
detectan más casos y donde se detectan
más muertes traemos la situación
específica de algunos países donde han
habido más casos en los últimos tres
meses por ejemplo vemos México con 182
casos en los últimos tres meses y además
estos casos en las últimas tres semanas
han aumentado respecto a las tres
semanas anteriores algo parecido sucede
en Brasil en cambio hay países donde en
los últimos tres semanas se ha revertido
la tendencia se detectan menos casos
como Estados Unidos Panamá y Argentina
pero es bueno recordar de nuevo eso que
el continente americano es la región
donde más casos se detectan hoy en día
mar y disculpó una pregunta que me surge
y así precisamente tiene algo que ver
con el estigma el hecho de que la OMS
recomiende no usar la palabra monkey Box
o viruela del mono sino en pox sí es
precisamente por el estigma que se puede
asociar al nombre pero no solo por las
comunidades que están más afectadas
fuera de los países endémicos sino
también por el estigma que se puede
asociar al hecho de que la enfermedad
surgiera en África no y sabiendo que esa
misma palabra de ese animal es una un
término peyorativo que se ha usado
muchas veces para hablar de las personas
afro Claro que interesante mal Bueno
rápidamente Perdón Cuáles serían los
riesgos a futuros de que continúe Pues
precisamente esta enfermedad Pues la
verdad somos muy rápidos en olvidar las
crisis no las emergencias que hemos
sufrido y ya hay países por ejemplo que
no están ofreciendo las vacunas contra
la viruela del mono contra el empox
sabiendo que eso puede llevar a nuevos
repuntes precisamente de hecho la OMS
recomienda que se incluyan los
tratamientos y las vacunas en los
esquemas regulares de la salud de
atención a la salud especialmente en los
grupos de riesgo es muy Es cierto que es
muy difícil que esta enfermedad se pueda
erradicar completamente porque es un
virus que fácilmente salta a los
animales y de los animales a los humanos
y de hecho uno de los riesgos también
que existen ahí es que al haber saltado
a otros países el virus encuentre nuevos
reservorios de animales fuera de sus
reservorios tradicionales y que eso haga
que los brotes puedan ir resurgiendo en
países donde la enfermedad de nuevo no
era endémica no era normal que que
estuviera ahí no otro problema es que
además Pues por supuesto no habrá
tranquilidad sin dirigir la mirada Al
final a los países donde el empox es
endémico volvemos al continente africano
que ya estábamos mencionando si
revisamos por ejemplo las cifras
específicamente en esta región vemos que
la curva epidemiológica a pesar de que
destaca a partir de mayo 2022 este pico
no ha descendido de la misma forma o con
la misma regularidad en la que lo ha
hecho en los otros países ahí no hay
acceso vacunas no hay acceso a
tratamientos en la mayoría de países más
afectados como República democrática del
Congo y si no se consigue atenuar o
controlar la enfermedad y básicamente
nos exponemos a que la misma situación
que vivimos hace un año pueda volver a
suceder en cualquier momento y de hecho
para terminar este bloque no en la
reunión que hubo en febrero de este año
para que mantuvo la emergencia
Internacional del enmpox uno de los
argumentos era que a pesar de que la
situación estaba controlada en países
del Norte Global en la región africana
No claro más bueno estaremos pendientes
de esta decisión seguro que nos la
traerá usted aquí a directo a América
cambiamos de tema pero seguimos también
con problemas de dificultad no para
acceder a ciertos tratamientos y vamos
precisamente a Venezuela donde es muy
difícil vacunarse contra el VPH sí
sabemos lo venimos diciendo en este
espacio no que la crisis económica y de
suministros y el bloqueo también que
afectan un país como Venezuela hacen que
sea muy difícil acceder a una amplia
variedad de medicamentos en este momento
nos centramos en la vacuna contra el
virus del papiloma humano el VPH no que
no es una excepción recordemos que es un
virus que al que pues la mayoría de
nosotros vamos a estar expuestos a
través de contacto sexual a lo largo de
nuestra vida el 80% de la población va a
estar expuesta al VPH pero el problema y
es que es carcinogénico Es decir que
puede generar cáncer puede dar inicio a
un cáncer especialmente cáncer de cuello
uterino en las mujeres o en las personas
con útero no y Venezuela es uno de los
pocos países de toda América Latina que
no incluye la vacuna del VPH dentro de
sus esquemas generales de vacunación
pública Entonces se debe suministrar de
forma privada y a raíz como decíamos de
esta difícil crisis económica que
atraviesa el país terminan siendo
fármacos con precios prohibitivos para
la mayoría de la población entre 120 y
300 dólares por una dosis de esta vacuna
Pero además también los problemas de
suministros hace que surjan dudas sobre
el buen estado de las vacunas una vez
llegan a vacunarse escuchemos
el problema que tú no sabes cómo fue la
cadena de frío esa vacuna tú no sabes
cómo llegó si esa vacuna no cumplió
vamos a decirlo así el traslado adecuado
a Temperatura adecuada no va a hacer
nada entonces muy probablemente Hay un
montón de gente que cree que se puso la
vacuna que cree que va a tener un menor
diez un riesgo de desarrollar cáncer de
cuello uterino y no es así porque la
cadena de frío no se está cumpliendo
marqué es sorpresa no esta cifra tan
alta de que el 80% de la población va a
exponerse a este virus a lo largo de su
vida no precisamente ante esta cifra le
pregunto Cuáles son los riesgos de tener
una población que no esté vacunada sí es
decir quiero hacer una puntualización Y
es que el 80 de la población está
expuesta a este riesgo pero no todo el
mundo digamos de la misma forma
significa que el 80% vayamos a
desarrollar una enfermedad a raíz de
esto sino que la mayoría de personas
pueden deshacerse de la infección de VPH
de forma natural pero hay algunas que no
y ahí es donde empieza el problema no
donde hay el riesgo bueno primero
decíamos no la dificultad de acceder a
la vacuna hace que si accedes a ella por
ejemplo algunos de los testimonios que
recogía el reportaje de afp que
estábamos del que estábamos viendo un
fragmento ahora hace que las mujeres
lleguen a acceder a la vacuna cuando
tienen alrededor por ejemplo de 25 o 26
27 años cuando ellas mismas se pueden
costear estas vacunas Qué sucede que en
lo más habitual es que alrededor de esta
edad ya se haya estado muy expuesto al
VPH No ya se haya tenido una vida sexual
activa que aumenta el riesgo de estar
expuesto al virus y que por lo tanto
hace que la vacuna pierda efectividad si
te vacunas después de ya haber expuesto
repetidamente el VPH pues tiene menos
sentido vacunarse por eso se recomienda
en la mayoría de países aplicarla
durante la adolescencia lo segundo es
que una población ampliamente vacunada
otorga una inmunidad de grupo no y
protege incluso las personas que no
están vacunadas y si no se consigue eso
pues todas las personas van a estar en
riesgo claro este es el argumento no
siempre para convencer a la población de
que se vacune que no tiene efectos la
vacunación Solamente sobre el individuo
sino sobre el colectivo Muchas gracias
por este repaso Gracias Rosa